[Music]
in the world of film fantastic costumes
and props are made by skilled craftsmen
to bring the characters to life now
these costumes they always looked so
real like they were actually made for
these characters to use in their jobs
and before I started corridor digital
with Sam I always wondered how these
costumes were made now early next year
we have the opportunity to shoot a
destiny two short film and for that we
are going to be making a Guardian hunter
costume so from the helmet to the boots
in this video we are going to show you
every step of the way how to make a
cinema a quality costume it's a whole
bunch of different techniques a lot of
doing people working together to make
this happen so we're gonna see if we can
pull this off in one week I'm here with
Kai from Commissar props and he's going
to be helping us put together this
costume we're going to be building the
exodus down armor set with a celestial
Nighthawk helmet this is the plan here's
how we're going to build the costume
starting with the helmet the easiest way
to do that in my opinion is a 3d print
next up is going to be the cape the hood
and the cloak we've got this area kind
of stunning here and here kind of this
segmented like heavily padded areas and
so I've decided that we're gonna go for
some nice leather for the padding we're
gonna be using a VA foam cut into
squares and blocks so next up we have
the chest plate so we will be using a
PVC plastic material sculpted and cut to
get the shape we need for the chest
plate now underneath all this armor we
need a base layer for that we're just
gonna use a basic under armor style
shirt has a full hexagon pattern easy
peasy
up next is gonna be from here to here
cool kind of Han Solo utility belt after
that we have this kind of two-tone pants
but then finally I like the boots and
gloves and other little accessories the
boots were just going to buy motorcycle
boots anything with the gloves there's
gloves out there that very closely match
what we need in this costume then
finally it's not here in the picture but
we're going to be also building a mida
multi-tool now that's going to be 3d
printed divided into a whole bunch of
pieces and printed on a whole bunch of
different printers by our friends over
at mater hackers this entire costume
needs to be done by next Friday today's
Thursday so we basically have one week
always remember to keep it to the
references print out your stuff keep it
around you all of that little bits of
information that you're just absorbing
by seeing it out there it helps you keep
on track and keep it accurate because if
you don't do that you're gonna stop
going off into memory and your memory is
not as perfect as those references
exactly
for most of the armored pots of this
entire build including the helmet the 3d
printing method is going to be a lot
more exact a lot more science space and
a little bit sci-fi witch and I think
it's kind of cool
kai asked me to print out the pauldron
for him we might be able to get from a
3d model that already exists but there
isn't one
so I have to model it myself it's a
relatively simple straight it's this
thing right here so I actually started
working on it it's coming along pretty
well I got the basic shapes down I'm
just putting in some of the details here
I do a low poly model first so that way
I can manipulate all the edges actually
I'm only working on one half and
ignoring the other because I'll apply a
symmetry modifier to it which will
mirror the half over to the other side
and give it more of the shapes I'm
looking for and then finally a
turbosmooth modifier which will smoothen
it all out because the printer will
print it like this you'll see those
faces if it's not high enough resolution
so a couple more details to model into
here and this will be ready for printing
so I'll be printing this in about ten
minutes
all of those cool padded leather bed
seven we were talking about it's all EBA
foam with leather over the front of them
and they look and feel like pretty nice
this whole area is what we're working on
right now around it here kind of
wrapping all the way around is a kind of
like gautier or kind of neck guard and
it's got padded raised areas we're gonna
do blocks of foam and rack and leather
when this gets all sewn together we're
gonna get a hold of a big leather sewing
machine we're gonna be doing lines for
it so it's all gonna get divided out
it's gonna look pretty cool this is
gonna go right about here and then
there's gonna be an extra bit but kind
of belt going around here we ran into an
issue the print failed how could such a
print fail well this happened overnight
when I was sleeping
so usually it feeds out do-do-do-do-do
like that and somehow plastic filament
have gotten spooled in underneath so
basically to tie itself into a knot yeah
it stopped feeding into the machine but
unfortunately it's a 22-hour print that
we have to start over again
we are now exactly one week from the due
date I just started it again it's going
I work in the creative clutter the
offices where is the clutter this is the
rough outline of the chess piece there's
several different layers to this thing
marking out the details I'm gonna find a
way to kind of like plane it off and
smooth it because there's this flat
plate here but then it really gradually
curves there are these very like beveled
edges as well let's let's cheat you this
way this main area here only Kaneko was
talking about that has to be armored and
looked kind of tough and rugged but the
rest of this gear and all of this
midsection here we're gonna have this
kind of like leather waistcoat kind of
crop top type thing that we're gonna
stick Nico and the armor is going to be
attached all
I swear this will look like a good
costume eventually give me give me some
time people okay it's a process so the
Select shield Nighthawk helmet so I have
a 3d model everything's looking great I
sized it up we measured everybody's
heads in the office and it looks like
it's all good to go the thing is it's a
very complicated model I don't know for
sure if there's going to be any print
issues so I'm thinking I will scale it
down print out a miniature version and
if that miniature version works I'm good
to go with the full-scale one I've
pretty the helmet success
it's about cat size but this turned out
just fine looks good scale looks good
he's gonna get sundown we don't want to
do that much like heavy drafting and
sewing and patterning and things like
that sometimes an easier way of doing it
is have something existing chop it up
lay it flat and now we've got our path
and it'll be exactly what we need to
make our under rig for holding the rest
of his gear together the upper arm is
gonna have this like padded area here
buckle belts kind of coming around on
the sides on top of that you're gonna
have this little shaped piece here like
sitting on top of here as like a little
extra armored shoulder there's only
gonna be one of these pads and then on
this side we're gonna have the padding
as well the bus new walls this side this
sides were holding guns one shoulder pad
one knee pad so it's okay to drop down
to this knee but if you do this then
you're gonna die mailing me so we just
drove an hour down the 5 here to come
visit matter hackers now matter hackers
is going to be helping us with the mida
multi-tool and the celestial Nighthawk
helmet but they actually have a whole
farm of printers and they can print out
the individual pieces across each one so
for example the helmets probably broken
down to about 10 or so pieces and across
10 printers are all printing equally at
the same time so it should be ready now
so these prints don't work we will not
be able to have this costume done in
time before we all leave for Christmas
and we'll miss the deadline so I hope
they work
150 hours total for the rifle Wow and
like 119 still in it
alright there you go ready oh wow look
at that Wow
it's like it's just real duct tape
together next up from Ida is this super
fragile or can i you can hold it yeah it
shouldn't it's super glued together that
looks something yeah absolutely yeah
this is cool
the big question are you 3d print
something is always in size question
would you like to take something from
yes that's polygons we realize it's real
life like will it actually fit in your
hands and it's like really comfortable
it fits right in the shoulder this looks
great
thank you for your expertise and your
craftsmanship your time so big things to
matter got customer help us out with
this welcome all right we're gonna hop
back in the car cos they think the whole
suit done by Friday have fun with that
well it's great you know last-minute pad
could be a big inspiration what I'm
doing is I'm working on the elbow pad
here and as it gets built up it's gonna
end up looking more and more like what
we're trying to make it's gonna be kind
of cool I think once I've gotten one of
these made we need two of them so what
I'm gonna try and do is make some
symmetrical and then I'll show you guys
how I make a quick mold so I can cast up
a couple of these doesn't look like much
right now looks like a poop now it's
gonna look pretty cool
yeah if you're gonna go all out with
spray paint you don't want to do a janky
masking job this is what we're going for
we got these from Bungie directly they
hooked us up with what they call
turnaround sheets for everything that
we're building this particular
instrument it's gonna require a ton of
very particular masking so I got the
little tiny stuff that the custom car
guys use so I've never done anything
quite this complex but as you can see I
think if we take our time and do it
right it's
turn out great don't you just saw that
time-lapse but Wow
look at all this masking took me two
hours to mask this thing and that's just
for one color there's three colors and
then I'm going to have to go in with a
fine detail and get like some neon and
some copper colors better for that how's
it going on a man John John good to meet
you we don't exactly have the time to
properly custom build the pants so
instead what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take two pairs of pants and we're
gonna stick them together basically this
is what we need so if you turn the
machine stitch this you're just gonna
stick the pant legs together and that's
not gonna work seized in the hand
stitching it once helped me with a few
things before and he's gonna be doing a
lot of the sewing for us and helping out
just tell me where percentage-wise
we are at from zero being nothing to
100% being someone's standing in the
costume with on camera taking pictures
of it so that's really hard to quantify
I mind you to quantify just tell me a
number you had to give me a number
gone into your head maybe like 50 50
yeah okay I'm gonna I'm gonna take that
with a grain of salt and I'm gonna
assume it's more like 40 maybe even 35
we're working on a hell of a deadline
that's too sure I'm feeling the pressure
I mean sleeping's optional right yeah
what leave when this done if you
remember early in the video I showed
that little elbow pad and I started
applying all of that putty over it after
I applied a bunch of layers of the VAT
and was grinding it down and sanding it
it ended up looking pretty good good
enough that I wanted to mold it okay so
we're gonna be making two or three of
them we're gonna use one for the knee
one for each of the two elbows what I
did is I took the elbow pad that I
wanted to use I took some clay and I
built it up inside of it and then stuck
it to the table and after I stuck it to
the table
I cut a bunch of cardboard and made a
fence around it after that I mixed up a
bunch of
silicon and then they filled out all of
that air through negative space around
this with silicon and so I made
something that looks like that yeah when
I flip it over and I take the clay and I
take the knee pad out all that's left is
the shape of the knee pad after that we
can take this stuff resin it's urethane
resin two parts mixed or in here
slush it around I just keep this is
often what's with referred to as a slush
test the nice thing with it is I can I
can do multiple coats beautiful yep all
right so my sanding is done and now I'm
going to wash this off which is no more
like then I'm going to prime if I don't
do primer on the plastic paint might not
stick to it so this will give me a great
base a little bit an issue we had to
start printing the helmet right away
because they're on a very short
timeframe for this project the desti 2
version of the helmet is pretty
significantly different than the Destiny
one version mainly in this part here
like the face mask breather etc we need
to come up with a way to change this
lower part to more accurately reflect
the destiny to hood profile this is
great that's all that's all gonna work
well looking at this the bottom half of
the helmet is a lot more slim or it's
like a rebreather or like a mass is like
you probably make something just using
one of our like gas masks or something
like that to cover this part instead
that would probably give us this profile
you know making a good costume is kind
of like jumping out on the aircraft and
sewing your parachute on the way down so
it's really just a case of finding ways
of getting things to rake and work
because there is no one strict yes or no
answer there's a whole bunch of ways we
could have done this none of them are
the wrong choice
one of the other steps that we're gonna
have to consider is once everything's
been built we've got to make it look
like it's literally jumped out of the
game the best way to do that is a really
good paint job we have to make
everything look kind of weathered and
worn best way to get those kinds of
effects I think is going to be using an
airbrush
what's up how are you good how's your
weekend going it's good it's going great
it's about to go really good though yeah
and this thing on test this video yes it
out
[Music]
Wow okay eat one of those the armor
looks great looks pretty good yeah they
got looks hey thanks man I'm the most
happy with how how much of a pulp we got
when we airbrushed everything taking it
from flat gold and then adding like a
little bit of darkness around a few
places really helps it go from flat
colors to depth and I dig that
[Music]